mais d'abord donc la grève des
enseignants ou comment arriver à cette
situation paralyser un service public
majeur en plein pic pandémique cécile
siksou poids lourd du gouvernement jean
michel blanquer serait-il en train d'en
devenir le maillon faible depuis la
rentrée 2022 le ministre de l'éducation
nationale pays les revirements sur le
protocole sanitaire à l'école en une
semaine le gouvernement a revu trois
fois sa copie ce qui a suscité une
déferlante de critiques contre lui et un
appel à la grève jeudi des enseignants
conséquence c'est le premier ministre et
non jean michel blanquer air qui est
monté au front et annoncé les dernières
simplification lundi sur france 2 j'ai
entendu les inquiétudes qui s'expriment
de la part des parents d'élèves des
enseignants des directeurs d'école et je
suis venu ce soir vous apporter leur
apporter un certain nombre de réponses
et de simplification une intervention
perçu comme un camouflet dans les rangs
de l'opposition de l'assemblée nationale
humilié pour les parlementaires de
droite il est appelé à la démission par
la gauche mais le porte parole du
gouvernement l'a sur le ministre a le
soutien de l'exécutif
il ya eu des difficultés depuis le début
de cette crise
et donc il doit ya une solidarité
évidemment entre les membres du
gouvernement que des décisions qui sont
prises sont prises de manière collégiale
je redis évidemment notre soutien au
ministre de l'éducation nationale dans
ce contexte cet après midi au sénat
interpellé à quatre reprises lors des
questions d'actualité il a défendu une
école ouverte mais n'a pas échappé aux
critiques des sénateurs il avait à tout
cela parmi les causes une qui vous
incombent et à vous seuls
celui d'une gestion solitaire rejetant
tout dialogue faisant apparaître le
bloquer risme pour ce qu'il est un
autoritarisme esseulé expliquant
largement l'étrange défaite dans lequel
sombre ce quinquennat en matière
d'éducation avec 75% de grévistes prévu
et la moitié des écoles fermées la
mobilisation de demain ce que de
fragiliser encore davantage le ministre
la stratégie du gouvernement à l'école
est le bilan que généralement du
ministre jean michel blanquer royal
thème de notre des vagues nous présente
mes invités tout de suite christine
rouzioux bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes professeur émérite en virologie à
l'hôpital necker sophie vénalité bonsoir
secrétaire adjointe du snes fsu les
enseignants du secondaire erwan balanant
bonsoir vous êtes député du finistère
vous êtes membre du groupe modem au sein
de la majorité présidentielle et vous
avez signé au tout début de cette année
une tribune avec un millier de
personnalités ils ont un plan à réélire
emmanuel macron pour que la révolution
de l'éducation et de l'apprentissage se
poursuit voilà les thèmes que vous aviez
employés avec nour duplex albert est
nous qui rédacteur en chef du service
politique du figaro dans soit albert et
nous bienvenus bon soyons évidemment
matthieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique est à mes côtés bonsoir
mathieu christine rouzioux le vrai pour
commencer avec vous faire un point sur
la phase de l'épidémie on bat chaque
jour un nouveau record en nombre de
contaminations est ce que ça veut dire
qu'on a un peu beaucoup je ne sais pas
perdu le contrôle de la situation oui
pour moi
on a pu le contrôler à plusieurs titres
c'est-à-dire que tous les positifs se
font pas testé en a pas on n'a pas
exactement le nombre de positif
réellement générale on estime qu'on ne
peut multiplier quasiment par deux les
chiffres que l'on trouve les tests senti
génique
sont bien répertoriés mais les les
autotests ne le sont pas donc on a quand
même un certain nombre de deux
d'indicateurs qui sont absents il ya 3 %
seulement des autotests qui sont qui
sont rentrés dans le système d'une
histoire la santé et en vain vers
l'adie très grandes difficultés à
confirmer un au total positif par pcr
les gens le font plus ou moins bien je
trouve les français relativement
responsables ils savent positif ils font
attention mais de là à les déclarer à
les rechercher un test pcr par contre
oui certains vont comme ils vont quand
même pour savoir négativité mais à ce
moment là c'est pas enregistrée comme
telle donc on n'a pas les bonnes données
ça c'est clair mais elles sont
faramineuses enfin c'est cette explosion
enfants adultes jeunes enfin voila c'est
mais
le fait est que la vaccination joue
vraiment bien son rôle et on n'a pas pas
beaucoup d'hospitalisation du fait de
cette vaccination c'est quand même le
point ce traitement positif et un point
positif est alors parlons d'un ton mais
on a peut-être un autre c'est l'agencé
européenne du médicament qui disait
aujourd'hui que le monde va peut-être un
sortir de la phase pandémique grâce à ce
variant omikron qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que ça veut dire concrètement en fait
enfin moi je parle pour la france
l'immunité collective quand même en
train de se développer parce que tous
ces personnes infectées clairement
acquiert une immunité alors le vaccin
c'est juste militer contre l'extérieur
du virus alors que quand on attrape
l'infection là on a on développe une
immunité globale non seulement contre
l'extérieur du virus mais contre les
protéines internes et là ça met en jeu
plusieurs systèmes dans la mémoire
immunitaire à la fois la réponse
anticorps est à la fois la réponse
cellulaire et donc c'est une réponse
composite un peu plus qui va qui va
compléter un la l'immunité vaccinale
donc on va renforcer et avec une limite
et hybrides chez un certain nombre de
personnes évidemment ce notre très
grande angoisse c'est cette explosion
d'infections virales chez les non
vaccinés ces vannes oc pied passe au
travers là et là chez eux le risque de
formes graves et est nettement nettement
supérieur à celui des vaccinés donc là
on est pas on a un mauvais message en ce
moment en disant ça va c'est un nouveau
virus il est moins fort et que cela il
est pas si moins fort que ça élite eu
malheureusement il tue et on parlera
notamment du cas particulier des enfants
avec avec vous tout à l'heure donc
l'économie elle galope on l'a bien
compris et le protocole de gestion de la
crise fait craquer les enseignants et
les parents d'élèves appellent à la
grève pour demain très suivie par
exemple dans le primaire voilà ce qu'on
annonce selon le snuipp-fsu qu'est le
premier syndicat du premier degré 75%
des enseignants 50% des écoles fermées
sauf civilité qu'est ce que vous
prévoyez pour demain dans le second deux
heures nous dans les collèges et les
lycées on n'a pas l'obligation de se
déclarer 48 heures à l'avancé donc on
n'a pas encore des chiffres bien
stabilisé mais là cet après midi dont on
a commencé à avoir des retours de la
part des surveillants et des cpe c'est
la vie scolaire et c'est eux qui sont en
première ligne notamment depuis dix
jours pour faire toute la gestion des
absences et des cas contacts et là on a
des chiffres de grévistes qui sont
supérieurs à 60 70 % dans les vie
scolaire avec donc des des surveillants
et des cpe qui sont très mobilisés
montrez bien là aussi qu' il ya un
ras-le-bol dans les bus scolaires ça
fait dix jours que les a aidé les
surveillants les cpe essaye de se
dépêtrer tant bien que mal des consignes
qui arrivent des ordres et contre ordres
et c'est ça aussi qu'on va dire que les
cpe les surveillants vont dire demain
que nous aussi en tant qu'enseignant on
va dire demain parce que je ne vous
raconte pas comment ça se passe dans nos
classes depuis dix jours ça devient
ingérable on n'arrive même plus à faire
notre métier et même on est mis en
difficulté parce qu'on ne sait même plus
ce qu'il faut répondre à nos élèves et
on est dans une gestion complètement
chaotique où aujourd'hui ben en fait ça
ne fonctionne plus et ce quelque part
c'est terrible de se dire qu'on se met
en grève pour pourra me pour essayer de
se protéger pour protéger notre santé
mais aujourd'hui après vingt mois
d'épidémie le bilan idée là la gestion
aller chaotique et aujourd'hui on ne
peut plus fonctionner alors erwan
balanant c'est vrai que les parents
d'élèves de la fcpe appelle aussi à riga
vous soutiens en tous cas cette cette
graine est ce que vous pouvez admettre
que ce protocole de cette rentrée-là
2022 même s'il a été revu même s'il a
été allégé c'est tout simplement une
erreur non je pense pas c'est compliqué
il veut pas dire le contraire moi je
suis j'ai une petite fille de 11 ans qui
au collège je vois bien que c'est
compliqué moi je suis en lien avec des
parents évidemment c'est compliqué pour
tout le monde compliqué pour les parents
c'est compliqué pour les enfants et
c'est peut-être la première chose qu'il
faut voir et c'est compliqué aussi pour
les enseignants pour les a aidés pour la
vie scolaire mais on a fait un choix on
a fait un choix de garder les écoles
ouvertes moi je je je je peux avoir
cette fierté d'être le pays où ça a été
le plus ouvert pendant toute cette crise
si l'école était fermée est-ce que vous
pensez que ça serait pas encore plus
compliqué pour les parents et pour les
enfants pour les enfants c'est sûr on le
sait les pédiatres le dise le fait quand
les enfants vont pas à l'école quand il
rate des longues périodes d'école c'est
pas bon pour eux et on voit qu'il ya
beaucoup d'enfants qui en souffrent pour
les parents c'est la catastrophe parce
qu'il faut s'organiser on peut plus
aller au travail donc vous voyez que
fermer l'école complètement serait une
alternative en réalité saurait et
essorés eu un facteur dans kick in man
bien supérieure pour une bonne partie
français donc on fait un choix qui est
un choix difficile et moi je comprends
je comprends la tension je comprends la
fatigue des enseignants déjà eu des des
cpe parce que le directeur d'être des
directeurs d'établissements parce qu'ils
ont une pression c'est compliqué dans
les compliqué pour vous avez c'est
compliqué pour les soignants il faut pas
oublier ça il ya y voilà assurez vous
avez fait référence sont effectivement
au nombre de jours de semaines de
fermeture on a regardé on a cherché les
chiffres alors on a trouvé des chiffres
du début de la pandémie jusqu'au mois de
mars
alors il ya une islande qui sur cette
période fait mieux que la france six
semaines sinon l'agencé dix semaines
ensuite on à l'espagne 15 semaines
l'allemagne 24 ni taille 32 et or si on
sort de l'europe etats-unis 40 cette
semaine est l'un de 50 et une semaine
albert zone où est ce que je vais rester
sur cette question là sur finalement ce
qu'est la philosophie du gouvernement et
donc du ministre de l'éducation
nationale de l'école ouverte est ce que
c'est un set à m quand même au bilan
positif du gouvernement dans la gestion
sanitaire et scolaire de cette crise
tout à fait c'est le gouvernement avait
aller cette ambition et surtout et mâcon
de présenter comme comme bilan une école
qui restait ouverte et la plus ouverte
possible ça c est à mettre au crédit au
crédit de manuel da cruz et mai et là on
touche on touche tout le problème c'est
que les problèmes aigus c'est que ce
bilan il se dit bien se heurter avec la
réalité de la cacophonie de ces derniers
jours avec avec des protocoles qui
change trois fois en quatre jours ça a
été et est donc allé mais n'est jamais
fiable anker qui était présenté comme au
début du quinquennat serait si vous en
rappelez vous c'était la star le
gouvernement on parlait même de blank
réalisations du gouvernement tant il
était présenté comme le ministre qui a
réussi c'est parce qu'il est à la fois
très technique il était politique il
venait de la droite et il a amené une
partie de l'électorat
avec lui et donc ils apporter quelque
chose et là depuis depuis en fait depuis
quelques semaines depuis quelques mois
il se trouve confronté à une montée en
puissance au but dans son ministère même
dans ses administrés si le dire d'une
teinte de révolte et la cacophonie en
effet entraîner une exaspération total
on voit bien que l'image l'hôpital
public la l'éducation nationale a touché
a touché quelque chose de très profond d
organisation adverse et d'institutions
pardon nous interrompre mais on va
revenir notamment sur le bilan de jean
michel blanquer en général et mais ça
non mais c'était passionnant et ça et ça
lance bien le le débat pendant que vous
parliez tout le monde ne faisait signe
pour pour intervenir je sais pas par qui
commencer peut être par vous
alors moi virologues personnellement
j'aurais pas prêt ou vers l'école ouais
moi je trouve que tout est plongé les
vacances quoi j'aurais prolonger les
vacances dix jours c'était pas
dramatique pour les enfants alors que là
on est à plus de 500 milles enfants
infectés faut quand même voir les choses
le bilan va être assez terrible le
fumier les formes au grave on va les
compter dans quelque temps il ya
maintenant des formes cliniques de pim
ce qu'ils sont bien définis trois quatre
cinq semaines après la l'infection les
enfants peuvent faire un syndrome
inflammatoire important donc il faut que
les parents sachent 1 ce qui peut
arriver chez ces enfants affectés qui
les surveille bien et tous les dix jours
pour mettre en place des protocoles pour
mettre en place les tests anti génie qui
soit faite il ya des tas de parents qui
savent pas faire s'était sentie gênée il
ya des parents qui sont quand même un
petit peu
vraiment terrorisée à l'idée de de ce
protocole qui leur est tombée dessus
autant que aux enseignants donc je
trouve que la mise en place même qu'une
petite semaine aurait permis quand même
de voir que on était on savait que cette
vague allait être un tsunami on le
savait donc c'est vrai que les enfants
aiment ils étaient mieux à l'école etc
mais là on était dans une période on est
dans une période que j'entends et c'est
un peu ce que disait albert dino erwan
balanant c'est que finalement la
stratégie d'école ouverte
elle était peut-être valable mais où
jusqu'à omikron quoi c'est ça il fallait
peut-être là jamais parce que le virus a
changé quoi j'ai c'est facile à dire
jusqu'en début j'entends bien c'est fait
il a dit oh voilà je suis assis sur mon
fauteuil je crois mais là c'est le
plaisir exactement
le c'est facile à dire ouais c'est
facile à dire moi moi j'ai discuté avec
plein de virologues ils me disent mais
même nous parfois on donne un certain
nombre de conseils qu'on n'aurait pas
donné trois quatre semaines avant
annonce à ce sujet alors moi je vais
donner de noms mais toutes les vacances
mais voilà vous l'avez donné
l'expérience là dessus mais il ya un
choix et le choix de garder l'école
ouverte vous dites dix jours c'est pas
beaucoup pour les enfants mais vous vous
rendez pas compte que ces dix jours
c'est dix jours ces deux semaines deux
d'école et deux semaines d'école quand
on est en sixième quand on est en cm2
c'est beaucoup de temps d'apprentissage
perdu et tous les parents n'ont pas la
capacité de s'occuper correctement de
donner des enseignants des enseignements
à leurs enfants moi je vois bien
conséquent on verra les conséquences les
conséquences les pédiatres aujourd'hui
le dise et vous avez vu l'exemple vous
avez montré les états unis 46 semaines
de fermeture sur les deux ans ça veut
dire presque pas tout à fait sur les
deux ans et jusqu'à mars 21 d'accord
jusqu'à mars 21 mais vous vous rendez
compte 46 semaines de non scolarisation
ce que ça veut dire alors l'école de la
république c'est une grande victoire je
pense que vous le savez où la passion
que vous avez de l'enseignement et tout
l'intérêt et de la vigilance que vous
avez quels que soient les gouvernements
pour que l'enseignement soit jamais
délaissé fermer ces délaissés l'école à
mon sens mais voilà après je bats je
vous tendait la perche a soulevé la
transition est toute trouvée sur la
question de l'école ouverte c'est on
entend beaucoup jean michel blanquer a à
chaque fois répondre et col ouvert
d'ailleurs c'était même le titre de son
livre vu à quel point c'est son marqueur
et pour nous en tant qu'enseignants
enfin il n'y a pas de débat bien
évidemment que l'école elle doit être
ouverte bien évidemment que les collèges
et les lycées ils doivent être ils
doivent être ouverts et c'est vrai que
cette capacité à focaliser le débat sur
bison extrêmement binaire école ouverte
aux écoles fermées ou en tant
qu'enseignant pour nous c'est pas ça le
débat le débat c'est le mélange pardon
mais face à omicron est ce qu on pouvait
garder l'école ouverte sans mettre en
place un protocole enfin considérer que
c'est une usine à gaz qui est trop
compliquée qui étaient impossibles à
classer qu'il a fallu l'amendé mais
est-ce que c'était possible
justement ce qu'on a dit c'est que ces
écoles ouvertes avec les protocoles
adaptés avec la sécurisation adapté et
bien souvent jean michel blanquer re
s'est arrêté à l'école ouverte et à
chaque fois qu'on a dit me fau les
moyens de sécuriser l'école et leurs
protégés je vais juste terminée parce
que je vous ai laissé finir de protéger
les élèves et les adultes on n'a jamais
eu de réponse tous des réponses
extrêmement tardive ça fait quand même
vingt mois 20 mois qu'on demande des
masques chirurgicaux et jean et jean
louis alors merci jean castex a annoncé
il ya une semaine au bout de vingt mois
de pandémie alors je sais pas s'il faut
applaudir un mais quand même au bout de
vingt mois de pandémie notre employeur
n'a pas été capable de nous fournir des
masques chirurgicaux on avait des
masques en tissu enfin les basques en
tissu ou il me tombait sur la bouche ils
n'étaient pas adaptés ça fait vingt mois
on parle d'aération qu'on parle de
capteur de co2 on a peut-être avancé de
5 mètres sur une course de 100 mètres
ouais et peut-être que même les masques
chirurgicaux ce sont là des signes ou
les mieux adaptées face à omicron c'est
ça si elle terminée dans la question de
l'école ouverte mais vraiment nous on
souhaite qu'elles soient ouvertes avec
un protocole adapté et j'entendais bah
oui l'école l'école ouverte c'est un ca
métro crédit jean michel blanquer pas
pardon mais c'est quand même nous qui
depuis 20 mois tenons les écoles les
collèges et les mais c'est entièrement
de seul souvent seul au milieu des
ordres et contre ordres on s'est
débrouillé on a tenu quand on découvre
au dernier moment des annonces dans la
presse et d'abord dans la presse le
lendemain on est face aux élèves on est
face aux parents et on a tenu pendant 20
mois sauf que là au bout d'un mois
ainsi plus possible de fonctionner bien
encore avec des tournevis pour ouvrir
nos fenêtres non dans nos salles non
mais alors et le débat école ouverte et
alors l'année les pâtes huile létourneau
musée va ouvrir les salles le débat
vous nous protéger et comment vous
protéger les élèves et au bout de vingt
mois la réponse elle n'est toujours pas
arrivé c'est ça le bilan de jean michel
blanquer c'est un bilan que voilà que
vous faites que je vais pas dire
caricatural c'est votre vécu je vais pas
le juger mais le bilan c'est aussi
d'avoir maintenu le système à flot et
c'est pas simple vous parlez des
fenêtres les fenêtres avec un tournevis
cesser les collectivités locales qui
sait le rôle des collectivités locales
risquons pas l'état n'est pas
impressionné parce que l'état l'a fait
l'état débloqué 20 millions pour les
équipements et 20 millions pour les
capteurs de co2 par rapport à ça c'est
pas si si ça suffisait vous faites le
calcul pour les capteurs doivent pas
laisser
fait une division par le prix des
capteurs vous arrivez à un certain
nombre de capteurs très inquiète en
place et un but et ça c'est une analyse
ça c'est un aide pour les collectivités
mais c'est les collectivités sont
responsables de deux de ces voix là
après on peut dire que on peut enlever
un niveau de décentralisation et que
l'état reprenne le dessus c'est une
solution aussi pour moi je
vais reprend la même seconde on va on va
avancer un peu on n'a pas encore entendu
mathieu que je suis sur plein de choses
à nous dire et je vais redonner la
parole à albert emon dans un instant
mais je voudrais aussi on va partir sur
un domaine peut-être un peu plus
politique sur les conséquences
politiques parce que cette grève elle
offre aussi un axe data cause opposant
d'emmanuel macron notamment tient
valérie pécresse était ce matin sur
france 2 ce qu'on voit c'est un désordre
et un chaos généralisé dans l'école et
moi je ressens cette immense souffrance
d'à la fois de la communauté éducative
c'est surtout des parents parce que on
ne sait pas si les enseignants sont là
on ne sait pas quel est le protocole à
suivre aujourd'hui vous voyez bien que
on maintient ouvert c'est une fiction
même les maires sont objets étaient
fermés on n'arrive même pas à porter les
repas dans les cantines parce que les
prestataires d'europe à eux mêmes non
plus les personnels non moi j'aurais eu
une autre gouvernance que celle
d'emmanuel macron il faut pas une
présidence solitaire et autoritaire qui
décide tout seul et qui dit c'est comme
ça et pas autrement il faut réunir les
maires pour voir quelles sont leurs
problèmes réunir les chefs
d'établissement l'urgence est là les
fidèles de l'équipe de l'ecoute j'aurais
pris le parti de l'ecoute le manque de
concertation ça va être un des thèmes de
de votre chronique mathieu vous allez
nous en parler mais d'abord cette grève
demain qu'est ce qu'elle traduit pour
vous mais moi la question qui me
turlupine c'est comment on en arrive en
pleine vague pandémique à se retrouver
avec un mouvement de grève qui risque de
paralyser l'éducation nationale demain
il ya bien sûr des raisons
circonstancielles serdy celle des
derniers jours on vient d'en parler un
trois protocoles en une semaine une
communication défaillante et au final
l'impression si on est sympa d'une
adaptation en temps réel parce que cette
gestion de crise avait compliqué et puis
si on est moins sympa d'un gros
cafouillage une forme de mépris
gouvernemental au nom du fameux adage
l'intendance suivra et aussi sans doute
en toile de fond un contexte plus
politique celui de la campagne
présidentielle on sait que certains ont
des arrières pensées et que certains
n'hésitent pas je dis pas tout ça mais à
une forme d'instrumentalisation médias
surtout des raisons structurelles plus
profonde peu sournoise plus révélatrices
j'allais dire qui traduit une certaine
vision des rapports sociaux par le
pouvoir depuis l'élection des modèles
macro sea jean michel blanquer on est là
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il a choisi une
stratégie de rupture avec les syndicats
enseignants alors bien sûr dans les
histoires divorce est toujours difficile
de savoir qui a arrêté de parler à qui
en premier et les torts sont évidemment
partagé mais comme une ministre c'est
comme du même lui le responsable de la
situation manque de concertation
dialogue de sourds consensus impossible
depuis son arrivée de rue de grenelle
jean-michel bancaire a choisi de mener
ces réformes de l'éducation au pas de
charge avec ou sans les syndicats c'est
à dire en fait plutôt sans alors ça peut
marcher si vous décidez de passer ou de
tenir bon c'est pas la rue qui gouverne
comme disait l'autre les réformes tombe
d'en haut et la base se débrouille là où
la méthode pose problème c'est qu'à un
moment ça finit toujours par casser en
particulier en période de crise comme
avec cette pandémie et en particulier
quand après leur avoir marché dessus et
vous demander sous tellement vos
interlocuteurs de se montrer
compréhensif de se montrer patients de
faire preuve d'initiative le vertical
tout d'un coup on appelle à
l'horizontale et généralement ça fais
pas tu as travaillé est ce que c'est la
méthode blanc caire non car il n'est pas
le seul enfin prenez un autre ministre
eric dupond moretti à la justice lui
aussi est en rupture de dialogue avec
les syndicats alors faut reconnaître que
les syndicats l'attendait au tournant le
jour même de sa nomination est lui aussi
mais se retrouve dans une situation et
tout ça pourquoi parce que l'exemple en
fait il vient d'en haut de la vision
qu'a longtemps lionel macron des
rapports sociaux des corps
intermédiaires il avait théorisé en 2017
en promettant de passer au delà de tout
ce qui selon lui bloquait l'esprit de
réforme en france alors il ya la rente
politique la rente étatiques et la rente
syndicale tout accusé d'entretenir
l'immobilisme du jeu monde et lui à
coude ordonnance de décision solitaire
et de vote d'un parlement souvent aux
ordres et ben il a tenté d'en faire fi
il en paye aujourd'hui le prix dans la
rue reste à savoir s'il en perd demain
l'abri dans les urnes albert et nous
quelle question des risques politiques
de de la grève de demain pour pour le
président la république pour emmanuel
macron salon
c'est se couper d'une partie de la
population
et d'avoir donné l'idée que sa gestion
de la crise et qu'ils misent beaucoup là
dessus pendant un temps on avait cru
bien cru comprendre que le mac on
voulait ne pas être le président de l'as
de la crise sanitaire vous voulez sortir
du coc vide et rentrer en campagne avec
d'autres thèmes pour ça qu'il avait
lancé la france en 2030 et donc il
voulait sortir de cet univers là et là
ils étaient rattrapés avec au micro
ondes la terre attrapé par la crise
hilarant il retarde naturellement soins
dentaires aux campagnes et et celle qui
sait de cette crise scolaire et cette
crise c'est l'idée revient bien se
heurter complètement avec sa stratégie
de la stratégie renforts en vue de
l'élection présidentielle et jean michel
blanquer qu'il était qui a été présenté
comme j'avais dit tout à l'heure comme
comme la star ne l'est plus il intrigue
à l'elysée ce qu est ce qu on a appris
nous aujourd'hui alors que le président
avait le sentiment que donnait le
sentiment que dans cette crise il avait
tout fait pour avoir une école ouverte
elle rester le plus longtemps possible
donner aux parents la possibilité
d'envoyer des enfants d'école à donner
aux enfants la possibilité d'être d'être
instruits et il se trouve avec un jean
michel blanquer requis en totale
contradiction avec sa stratégie est
halal alors même que dans d'autres
secteurs par exemple
roselyne bachelot elle alors qu'elle a
elle a connu le monde de la culture est
connue d'un enfermement une deuxième
fermeture des fermetures beaucoup plus
longue s'en sortent beaucoup mieux et
pour emmanuel macron avoir avoir jamais
charles blanc caire dans son équipe
c'est aujourd'hui c'est le présenter
comme un boulet donc servir et à la
mienne dit aujourd'hui que tout le monde
le souhaitait et quand ils sautaient
même fortement mais il n'empêche que ça
reste ça reste une d un caillou dans la
stratégie de magnet mâcon pour la
présidentielle mais ce n'est pas
toujours bon signe quand un porte parole
du gouvernement annonce qu'il soutient
un ministre erwan balanant je les dis
quand je vous ai présenté le 1er janvier
dernier vous avez signé n'hésitez pas
c'est alain loin de là il y avait 1200
membres de la communauté éducative des
citoyens engagés pour l'école un appel à
la réélection des manuels macro et je
cite de nouveau pour que la révolution
de l'éducation et de l'apprentissage se
poursuivent donc vous faites forcément
un bilan qui est pas du tout celui de
d'albert et nous pourquoi non mais je
crois que cris il faut faut il ya deux
choses à dissocier il ya eu cette
période là d'un mois de cette semaine de
rentrée compliquée c'est facile de taper
sur le ministre parce que tout le monde
est fatigué dans ce pays tout le monde
on le voit bien tout le monde est tendu
tout le monde en a marre de cette crise
et les soignants croyez que les
soignants ils font grève non ils sont là
et c'est eux qui souffrent le plus
aujourd'hui de gens qui ne se sont pas
vaccinés par exemple et et voulait bien
rappeler donc il ya un état de fatigue
général mais il y en a appelé à la
responsabilité jampel pas la responsable
d'agencé ailleurs en france je pense que
vais faire générer de la ligne azur pays
c'est un droit et c'est un bon droit et
souvent ça permet de faire passer des
messages et que les syndicats fassent
grève aujourd'hui c'est leur droit mais
essayons de garde gardons raison par
rapport à la situation il ya une
situation de fatigue généralisée une
situation de fatigue généralisée
certainement chez les enseignants
nouioui zone et oui mais si la régie
s'est fragilisée dans un contexte est
facile à c'est quand même pas seulement
un problème politique il faut aussi
trouver quelqu'un sur qui taper en ce
moment parce que depuis le début et les
français vous le diront on a là une
trouve que le gouvernement assez bien
géré cette crise les sondages 57%
récemment 10 et manière il y aurait pas
de président koré fait mieux qu emmanuel
macron 57% des français c'est quand même
pas rien donc il ya un moment donné
devant cette fatigue il faut trouver
quelqu'un sur qui taper et évidemment
c'est conjoncturel
là on a une situation tendue à l'école
effectivement vous aviez plus de tests
ils sont arrivés depuis aujourd'hui je
suis passé dans la pharmacie avant
d'arriver ils étaient les tests c'était
marqué tests disponibles voilà bon ça
c'est un côté puis de l'autre côté il ya
le bilan des quatre ans et demi presque
cinq ans de mandat et là-dessus - l'on
demande à tous les missiles les jours
national
de l'éducation nationale depuis très
longtemps et ce sera le premier je crois
qu'il fait un quinquennat entier c'est
pas ça veut dire quelque chose aussi et
là tout est là dedans je crois que on
avait une situation très compliquée on a
rattrapé un certain nombre de choses on
a fait le dédoublement des classes on a
fait un certain nombre de réformes comme
parcours sud qui a été critiquée
aujourd'hui les parents et les étudiants
la trouve plutôt bien parce qu'il
préférait faire cette sélection que le
tirage au sort voyez il ya plein de
choses qui ont bien marché et c'est ça
qu'il faut et c'est ça qu'il faut
regarder ayant encore des choses à faire
et je pense qu'il ya des sujets il ya la
question de la rémunération il faut pas
que la crise sanitaire obscur 6 9 ans la
vision directe du bilan du mini bilan
kiki attention loin on dira aussi rien
tout n'est pas parfait puisqu'on peut
pas on peut pas on peut pas rendre
parfaite une école qui n'était pas
parfaite et qui est
si l'éducation nationale on a la chance
d'avoir ça dans notre pays et alors et
si on ne parle jamais pouvoir répondre
peut-être sur le fond mais d'abord je
voudrais quand même reprendre une
une critique ou un aspect delà de
l'intervention de m le tout à l'heure
sur le les arrière pensées est-ce que
vous menez avec cette grève aussi un
combat politique contre emmanuel macron
avec la présidentielle en ligne de mire
donc c'est une une organisation
syndicale on n'est pas un parti
politique donc on est là pour défendre
tout simplement les intérêts les cons je
vais quand même faire de la politique
c'est du syndicalisme nous on a pas on
n'a pas attendu la crise sanitaire pour
porter un jugement circonstancié sur la
politique qui est menée par par jean
michel blanquer vous parliez tout à
l'heure de la méthode blanc caire la
méthode blanc caire là effectivement on
a vu ce que ça donnait même avant la
crise la crise sanitaire quand il a été
question par exemple de la réforme du
baccalauréat c'est quelque chose on a
expérimenté où on a vraiment subi la
méthode blanc caire qui consistait à
avancer comme un bulldozer est
absolument pas écouter ce qu'on disait
et ça c'est ça a continué pendant la
crise sanitaire puisque j'entends
parfois ministre dira oui j'écoute les
organisations syndicales alors on l'a
rencontré la semaine dernière
il paraît donc je lui pose une question
sur la rentrée l'ebit scolaire au mois
de janvier il me parle de la rentrée
2022 donc est ce que c'est ça le
le dialogue social habitante de mails 22
septembre 2022 donc est ce que c'est ça
le dialogue social donc c'est une
méthode très verticale très autoritaire
et qu'il utilise depuis le début parce
qu'elle s'inscrit effectivement dans une
certaine conception de ce que doit être
le dire rejoint 302 alors c'est jean
rose la question un peu différemment sur
le le le bronze cette grève va la suivre
demain évidemment est-ce qu'elle
pourrait durer parce que là on est aussi
dans la question de l'enjeu de la
présidentielle de l'impact de cette
grève sur l'opinion et pour le l'avenir
d'emmanuel macron donc comment vous
voyez la suite est-ce qu'elle pourrait
durer c'est mieux mais c'est quoi votre
objectif on voit que la mobilisation
elle est partie pour être très important
pour la maîtrise toriques 1 avec
évidemment des taux de grévistes qui
sont très importants pour la suite on
comptera le bilan demain soir a priori
on ne s'interdit rien pour la suite
parce que nous on a quand même un
objectif c'est d'obtenir très rapidement
des moyens de protection et de
prévention dans les établissements
scolaires pour qu'on puisse fonctionner
c'est ça l'objectif c'est qu'on se
retrouve pas à courir derrière les
masques à courre aidara les tests à
s'arracher les cheveux le matin pour
savoir quel est le protocole sanitaire
qu'on va appliquer et à enfin obtenir
aussi un dialogue avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et obtenir une
méthode de travail qui soit respectueuse
des uns et des autres et après s'il faut
continuer pour obtenir ça on continuera
et on verra sous quelle forme mathieu au
delà des enseignants c'est peut-être
l'exaspération des parents que
l'exécutif screens de très près ou de
plus près ce que j'ai l'école est un
sujet inflammable d'une façon tout le
monde a un avis sur l'école mandat était
utilisateurs si j'ose dire il âgées et
aux parois là et puis et puis un million
il ya quand même de deux de personnel
enseignant donc donc c'est un sujet très
compliqué et qui n'est pas au coeur de
cette campagne présidentielle faut le
dire il ya certains candidats contenter
de le mettre en souvient de la
proposition très critiquée d'anne
hidalgo de doubler les salaires de tous
les personnels en contact avec les
enfants ou la plus récemment celle
d'eric zemmour de remettre tout le monde
avec une blouse
de faire un grand ministère de
l'instruction publique aurait voir
s'aimer mais sinon au delà de ces
slogans ou de seuil et de ses
propositions un peu chocs y a pas de
vraie réflexion sur la transformation de
notre de notre système scolaire c'est
comme l'hôpital au fond on est quand
même dans un moment particulier où on a
ses moments de tension ces moments
sociaux de 2,2 de grève ou de ras-le-bol
ou de colère et puis quand on a
l'occasion d'en débattre quand on a que
l'occasion de construire quelque chose
des propositions et ben il n'y a
personne derrière c'est souvent une
question de moyens combien vous allez m
vous allez m mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait
d'hôpital et de l'offre de soins en
france mais de l'offre éducative il n'y
a pas vraiment de répit d'ailleurs on en
parle et on a parlé lundi c'est
peut-être aussi que cette crise qu'ovide
par écraser un peu tout tous les autres
thèmes et à nous frustrer elle révèle
aussi des systèmes en pensez c'est vrai
mais elle frustre aussi les
personnalités politiques - nous sommes
qui avons envie de faire des
propositions on voit bien mois /
institut travaille sur un certain nombre
de sujets on voit bien qu'on n'arrive
pas à les enclenché dans le dans le dans
le spectre médiatique parce qu'il ya la
partie à la crise et c'est effectivement
frustrant et c'est pourtant des enjeux
qui sont des enjeux con qu'on doit
débattre en moments de campagne
présidentielle parce que c'est le moment
où il ya des montées voilà des sceaux
d'idées généralement un peu alors
récents pour information on va pas tous
les jours centré l'émission autour de la
crise sanitaire et on va même chaque
jeudi sanctuariser un rendez-vous qui
s'appellera demandez le programme où on
va prendre les grandes thématiques
voilà majeur structurante du du débat
politique pour les analyser on va
vraiment essayer de d'être dans ce bois
là dans cette promesse de recul sur les
grands thèmes de la de la présidentielle
et de cette campagne et christine
rouzioux je reviens là à la place des
enfants dans cette pandémie alors
peut-être que vous n'avez pas les mêmes
chiffres mais moi j'ai trouvé 400
enfants hospitalisés dont 80 en
réanimation à un chiffre qui a triplé en
un peu moins d'un mois 800 organisé
voilà et
la pédiatrie commence à sentir clem mais
alors ils sont où les enfants que pardon
du terme et qu'ils étaient à risque non
non c'est moi forcément non les enfants
à risque pour le coup la vaccination
s'est relativement bien développé
relativement rapidement non là le
l'enjeu c'est laval la vaccination des
enfants ça marche pas du tout des 50 à 3
% et remarques sur ça vient du tout il
ya eu les vacances scolaires qui ont
fait que les enfants étaient dispersés
effectivement ça mais là justement avec
ce désordre dans l'école les parents qui
doivent tester les enfants qui
reviennent qui sont qu'à contacter enfin
voilà on est dans un désordre tels que
les parents trop de choses à gérer pour
réfléchir à cette vaccination
je crois qu'il faut dire les choses
on est loin de d'imaginer qu'il ya plus
de risques même si les signaux et de
l'afrique du sud est de l'angleterre
montrent que les choses sont en train de
de diminuer le pic est en train de
baisser chez nous on est plutôt en
plateau on n'est pas du tout encore au
pic et donc il ya encore un risque réel
au moins pour pour trois semaines est ce
que vous pouvez dire aux parents qui
hésitent à faire vacciner le
leurs jeunes enfants que cette
vaccination c'est un bénéfice évident
par rapport aux risques de la maladie de
l'enfant en fait le c'est un bénéfice
vraiment important et et qui va le faire
une protection y compris sur
éventuellement un nouveau variant il
faut que la fal avec six notes la
vaccinologie c'est c'est la prévention
alors évidemment je le connais pas le
nouveau variant mais il peut être là en
mars en mai en juin ou en septembre si
les enfants sont vaccinés maintenant
voilà on aura fait de la prévention pour
pour vraiment un moment d'autant que la
réponse vaccinale chez les enfants est
toujours très forte et en plus c'est un
tiers de doses en face et voilà c'est
une opportunité on est dans un pays où
on a accès à la santé on a accès aux
soins on a accès au vaccin gratuitement
alors que les axes que les parents
réfléchissent et qu' il y ait un manque
d'information sans doute mais ça voilà
le manque d'information c'est les
vacances et cette rentrée je pense que
là il faut reprendre le flambeau et
réexpliqué la protection va être longue
et les vagues les coronavirus il va y en
avoir d'autres voilà je pense que
c'était important de faire mais sur la
vaccination des enfants mais finalement
je pense qu'il faut ici il faut y aller
voilà ce que j'avais quand même compris
des autorités sanitaires bon déjà ils
ont donné le go juste avant le pour la
vaccination des enfants juste avant les
vacances mais c'est mid100 mi décembre
ensuite il s'agit on est à quatre points
il y avait quand même un message qui
était donnée encore à ce moment là et
est toujours pour par certains par les
infectiologues en disant protégeons
d'abord les plus fragiles et vaccinés en
priorité encore les 65 50 qui sont pas
encore vaccinés et après on ira vers les
enfants et moi je pense que vous avez
sans doute raison enfin certainement
plus que moi parce que c'est quand même
votre métier c'est que c'est maintenant
qu'il faut aller vers la vaccination les
mains fort et peut-être que c'est aussi
un moyen de répondre à la crise mais
bien sûr sur les sur à l'école et puis
évidemment sophie dit et je reviens
puisque faute de vaccination il ya cet
enjeu majeur de protection des enfants
et des du personnel de l'éducation
nationale qu'est ce que vous réclamez
vous pour être mieux protégés irait
question des masques à la question des
capteurs est ce qu'on peut être précis
la question effectivement des masques
donc masque survivent aux masques ffp2
si besoin il ya la question des capteurs
et de l'aération des salles et la
question aussi de la politique de test
dans l'éducation nationale qui reste
quand même un espèce de grand trou noir
de cette de cette crise sanitaire dans
l'éducation nationale dans les collèges
et les lycées on ne testent plus depuis
des mois c'est à dire que il ya eu une
boîte d'autotest distribué aux élèves de
6e au peut-être avant les vacances mais
pour le reste on n'est pas du tout en
mesure de savoir ce qui se passe dans
les collèges et les lycées de savoir
exactement à quel moment on va peut-être
casser certaines chaînes de
contamination il y aurait traîné cette
femme forcément besoin d'affiner la
question de la politique des tests et
d'avoir en fait tout simplement des à la
fois des protections mais aussi des
règles lisible parce qu'aujourd'hui on a
perdu en lisibilité ce matin un élève
qui vient de voir qui me dit mais pas
qu'ils viennent voir ekindi mais je suis
qu'à contacter qu'est ce que je fais
bailly les annonces de jean-luc
forcément répondent et les annonces de
jean castex lundi soir mais on n'a pas
eu d'information depuis donc on ne
savait pas lui répondit a besoin de
lisibilité aussi mathieu pardon j'avais
juste une question est ce que la règle
la plus lisible et la plus protectrice
pour ça serait pas de réclamer la
vaccination obligatoire pour les
enseignants alors bien sûr la question
de la vaccination des enseignants mais
je rappelle briller tout juste un nom
quand on commençait à parler vaccination
en france qu'on a très vite dit il faut
que les enseignants soient prioritaires
sur sur la vaccination la demande et des
mois de janvier on ne l'a jamais mais la
mannschaft en parle de vaccination
obligatoire pour les soutiens en dépit
des obstacles nous ont été mis en sevice
signer très rapidement et aujourd'hui le
taux de vaccination chez les enseignants
il est très aisé il est de plus de 80
dans les centres raison qu'aujourd'hui
la question pour nous elle est patent
sur la vaccination alors que vous avez
deux façons un public qui est très
majoritairement vacciner parce qu'on
connaît les enjeux que de l'ensemble de
la protection des collèges et des lycées
oui à la cabine médecine on a on a
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
publiée et communiqués sur la
vaccination et pour nous c'était évident
que les enseignants devaient être
prioritaire au même titre que les
soignants c'était pour nous c'est aimer
mais c'est vrai que l'obligation
vaccinale est un fonds est un gros sujet
est d'ailleurs on va communiquer ces
jours ci l'académie communiqué ces jours
ci sur l'obligation vaccinale essayé de
pousser un petit peu le le sénat pour
responsabiliser faire sauf que c'est un
devoir civique de l'état en même temps
qu on demande un devoir civique oh non
vaccinés de se vacciner donc il faut que
ce soit dans les deux sens et que chacun
prenne ses responsabilités mais encore
une fois on est un pays où on a accès à
tout enfin c'est fou quand même réaliser
ce qui se passe au sud et à quel point
la carte de vaccination au sud est pâle
et il n'y a pas d'accès il n'y a pas
d'information c'est pas quel virus on
l'a enfin on ne sait même pas le taux de
mortalité un dédain des pays comme
madagascar c'est c'est catastrophique le
virus circule donc il faut quand même
utiliser les outils correctement et puis
et puis c'est vrai que ce vaccin n'est
pas parfait mais et qu' il faut
continuer que la vie va être continuer à
être perturbé qu'il faut continuer à
faire attention le masque etc et mais je
trouve que dans l'ensemble les français
on était quand même très responsable sur
un certain nombre de choses c est ce
assez il faut le remarquer il faut il
faut soutenir ça mais mais
le fait est que il ya un moment où cette
vaccination obligatoire enfin pour moi c
c voilà c'est en irak cesse et c'est une
chance bon mais on suivra effectivement
vos préconisations dans l'est dans les
prochains jours sur ce thème notamment
merci merci d'avoir le cisi paix à ce
débat merci albert et nous de nous avoir
de nous avoir suivi également je vous
dis à tous à bientôt sur public sénat